why don't we go next to
let's go to Jaden from Idaho Jaden
you're on the air
yes I can
okay
um yeah so I talked to my dad about
politics all the time
um he's kind of Center he just he kind
of just doesn't trust anything and uh
I'm trying to I think his biggest
obstacle is just uh trusting media and
uh I was just wondering what you think
is like the most efficient kind of way
about even if I could just get him to
trust One Source it doesn't matter if
it's Fox News or CNN or New York Times
or Associated Press he just don't post
any of them so what would be your advice
on that well let me see if I can find
out a little more when you say he just
doesn't really trust anything or anyone
is is he a conspiratorial thinker by
Nature
um he used to be I don't think he's that
way anymore he just
[Music]
um
yeah he just doesn't cuss media so what
is the so it's not that he thinks
there's sort of like an organized
conspiracy for media to lie it there
must be what is his reason for believing
media is not trustworthy
um I mean he just thinks they're
politically
um
just kind of
you know what I mean like uh
like CNN will only cover things and I'm
kind of idealized left-leaning way or
even like
um Associated Press which is I mean
really Center uh and does really good
but he he just believes that all of them
are kind of just uh reporting or their
political ideologies there isn't really
any sense to be honest which is why I'm
trying to yeah I mean you know what's
tough is if someone doesn't reason their
way into a belief it can be hard to just
reason them out of it but I think maybe
I would start with just some simple
questions like what is the incentive for
someone like Associated Press to report
political distortions my guess is that
he would say well as an institution they
want to see their ideology presented as
fact and and sort of like trick people
um to which I would say well with with
what eventual goal in other words how
what about how Associated Press is
organized would be served by lying to
people in a politically biased way and I
would just kind of start to get it
motive maybe but that's tough I mean
that that sounds really difficult
yeah yeah
I mean I think maybe another approach
would be to talk about listen uh find
some things that he believes and try to
figure out where he got those beliefs
and you will probably find that he got
them from media and so that might get
him to say oh you know what those are
things I learned from the media and at
least as far as he knows they're true
maybe that would Pierce a little bit and
then you could go from there
yeah okay
all right Jaden thanks for the call yeah
thank you pleasure
um let's see wow a lot of people today a
lot a lot of people today why don't we
talk to Ethan from Colorado Ethan you're
on the air hello David hi
uh do you ever see the United States
becoming more like the European social
democracies with the way the Republican
party is now
it was so I understand ninety percent of
the question what do you mean with the
way the Republican you mean as a result
of the Republican Party being so radical
yeah oh yeah maybe I mean you know the
thing that I don't love about these
questions is we're terrible at
predicting stuff we can't even predict
how many jobs are going to be created
next month and so when Trump uh goes and
says we will never be a socialist
country it's like yeah not anytime soon
but never is a really long time or at
least it's potentially a long time
um so I don't know I mean I think it's
totally plausible that if in the United
States the right continues to become
more and more cartoonish and we can take
control of gerrymandering because if
they become if the right becomes more
and more radical but figures out way to
suppress more and more of the democratic
vote they'll just keep winning and we
won't make any progress if we can hold
back the voter suppression and the
Republican right keeps going crazy you
will probably see uh decidedly leftward
move and who our elected official are
whether the U.S will ever be like
Denmark I don't know anybody who tells
you it will or it won't they really
don't know it's just a guess and I think
we're not going to know that until we're
closer to it if indeed that's the
direction we're going
okay my pleasure thank you for the call
a lot of efficient questions today
very very efficient
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman